yeah you know welcome to this broadcast
yeah I hope you all made it in time it's
really very punctual to start there
hello to all of you in the chat a couple
of guys already they're shedding away
okay let's get going a couple of
regulars also in there let's see if I
can get a 5-minute started blitz game
and playing bamboozler who is that Seren
name nope
so let's see what happens yeah my rating
is pretty much down the drain I played
the odd game over last one or two weeks
but I was really very busy and couldn't
really check yeah I didn't have
sufficient enough focus for for playing
some playing some high quality games so
I lost the odd game and I didn't really
didn't really get anywhere so I'm pretty
much
underrated think so
maybe I can do something good with that
low rating so playing bamboozled oh yeah
what's normal way of playing this is to
play with you four and I think that
black is okay after subsequent to you
five this is something that I had on the
board in in some games okay he goes you
five and this position interesting yeah
so I can take I can go 97 hmm well maybe
just 97 I don't think that I can't he he
doesn't want to take surprisingly okay
I'll take if I play you 5 him and see
what happens oh so he wants to open this
up directly Bishop g4 is an interesting
move in this position tried to take the
night the night doesn't have many
squares so I'm trying for this I don't
mind to take their own yeah my queen
side is a little bit weak a5 but still
97 95 maybe as he's on the cards he
would like to play 90 toward the queen
is on that square okay so I'm happy to
trade this good to put the knight on c5
yeah that's quite okay yeah so who's in
the chat then amber oh yeah regular guy
Biggus Dickus yeah and also also there
let's see 95 okay it's not going to fall
for night b3m but yeah i can actually
put the knight on d4 is that something
that I wanted this position maybe I do
win I also have Queen b6 as a possible
option yeah without consciousness what's
up with my channel is there going to be
more content in the future
yeah for sure it's just that
currently I'm extremely extremely busy
with stuff it's um the the summer is my
time for for the holidays and I'm having
returned from her from a small short
vacation a week ago and I'm going to be
on a vacation a longer one to to play
some chess and to relax next week
and in the meantime I have to work quite
a bit and get things on the gets get
things done work was and it just I
couldn't I couldn't do anything yeah for
my channel or I didn't have the time to
do something appropriate so there will
definitely be regular updates and stuff
in in the future
it will just be taking a bit of time mid
August is the like in one month the my
channel will be back on back on track
yeah this is a good question how to
recover when you feel played a bad game
and need to get usual gameplay back this
is not so easy and it's um it's
important to you take one game at a time
and don't be yeah don't be too
disheartened by a bad game it's it's not
so easy I think it helps a lot to have
experience and know that one bad game
doesn't mean it's it's it's a bad event
I mean what I definitely wouldn't do is
to look much at at the games at all
during the tournament yeah I mean it
doesn't really help - lets say switch on
the computer and the computer will tell
you all kinds of things that you did
wrong during the games right during the
event it's just going to be
frustrating don't do that yeah just
focus on the next games and don't think
so much about what yeah what could have
been what you should have done this is
something to learn from the games learn
learn your mistakes something to do
after the tournament
yeah not during the tournament during
the tournament I would focus on the next
game and not think so much about what
happened
thoughts on yesterday's final yes I I
watched it and I think that it was a
quiet deserved victory for Portugal I
think the French team didn't really
convince just like I'm not really
convincing here not good it's not not
great yeah yeah before the strong move
yeah he's playing this quite nicely
yeah the French team was a bit more
active but that was was to be expected
the other the Portuguese team didn't
check didn't play very active football
the whole event but they were very safe
in there in the defence and France
simply didn't score goals as simple as
it seems it reminded me a little bit of
the the Germany France match where
Germany also had had more and had more
yeah we had more how do you call it we
had yeah without canto says it's pretty
undeserved as France was the only team
that was pushing yeah if it's if it's
like that Germany should have won the
event because we were the best team
that's no question but we didn't score
goals and goals count this is the thing
yeah yeah and this is a very bad
position for me we also had France
completely in the back but they scored
two goals we didn't score any and you
have to do to make the best out of here
out of your chances yeah this is pretty
awful him this pollution time warning
I'm going to resign that I have no moves
and it was pretty awful
that was pretty awful the thing was I'm
moving around to to play Knight a7 which
really didn't have it all okay so let's
get a new game and see what what happens
yeah I see what you with this pushing
all the time starting it's it's
certainly true yeah France was the more
active team but if you don't score yeah
if you don't score and it's not like
France had super clear chances to score
goals I think I mean it was it was it
was nice but it wasn't like totally
convincing okay let's see what we get
here against the Rainmaker he's playing
this this opening line that I think it's
not particularly great but I'll see what
happens
so push them away here how to do that
Quincy - how to start with this move I
think that the knight on e5 is just not
particularly well placed and therefore I
think white should be better I think
this is a somewhat inferior version of
them King keto variation in the Kings
India inferior because my knight
placement is better okay I'll go in for
him it's not so easy for me to play f5
under favourable circumstances let's
push him away I haven't I haven't heard
about Quentin chess because that's a
chess with four sides playing or
something like that not a huge fan of
those chess versions let's aim
then Umbra mentioned the book chest
structures a grandmaster guide by
Grandmaster Flores real say it's a very
good book it's something that I
recommend a lot for students to study on
their own it is a very nice overview of
relevant porn structures and it's
something that will be helpful to form
basically all players it's just a very
nice book ok Knight e4 is possible you
can take on c4 I can also play the
bishop I mean he just has a pretty awful
night take this rook takes I take with I
play 94 yeah so this is a nice position
how is he going to cover this I can take
on a 5 and take on d6 even there I think
maybe he didn't appreciate that or I'm
overlooking stuff but as possible
Florence Noah raised floor he doesn't
think the Benoni structures lost so
black that would be quite ridiculous it
just written the Menomonee structure the
model inventory structure is risky but
this is nothing new yeah this is not
risky for black this is lost for black
but you never know I might screw it up
ok it's a tempo here on the Queen so I
will be able to take the roof next
okay so let's see I can push the pawn I
wonder if that is the strongest
continuation couple of things should win
here I'm not totally sure what's best
maybe let's break this pawn structure do
this first so put the bishop on d4 okay
huh that's something that I should have
prevented if possible that's not good
didn't play that well technically
yeah I played this badly giving him a
lot more than he should have got him
okay let's see that my rooks can do
something
maybe I'll still keep the deep on which
is something that I didn't expect to
happen take in five now rookie in one
stats winning not totally sure if he
takes it I've got before maybe time
warning playing a little bit too slowly
him rookie one's not going to work okay
let's move it let's move this cat's not
going to be easy
season one is also quite dangerous
there's a question about the two Knights
defense Bishop d7 on move six against c6
tough to and tough now to give you the
whole sequence
yeah [ __ ] I think you should play c6
Bishop d7 is not so convincing if you
have a good score with that I understand
that you kind of like to make it work
but c6 is China okay I'm going to push
the snow him check check I don't have
time to figured it out completely
yeah I came I should shoot to shoot one
in this game but I played it badly not
good
Jack I played it very badly technically
from at the start and made it very
difficult to win sorry
I was resigning you can't rely first
check
yeah that's pretty pretty although I
should have won that one
but okay and I said I'm kind of rusty at
the moon 3 e5 in the rustle demo
I have no opinion I'm sorry I think
you're talking about about this hmm
maybe I have my doubts it doesn't look
particularly like a putting in a
favorable structure ok I'm going to
shoot for another game there's a
question can up costed us he turned 18
years old and I mean this mm ah you see
EV playing chess for three years do I
have any chance of getting the IMO GM
titles what degree of dedication would
that take Grandmaster is tough it's
certainly tough but it's tough for
everyone I mean no matter where you
where you start that I am tired you can
definitely achieve
I think but dedication must be very very
high
I mean like invest every possible minute
and you have to be super dedicated yeah
then then you can do it
there's a question of a low maintenance
opening against one deform and for club
player game started yeah there are
capital low-maintenance openings but the
thing is what you are kind of position
you want I think an interesting approach
is to to play is to play the queen's
gambit accepted i think this is
something that i had mentioned earlier
and earlier streams i think but there
are a couple of things that you can
certainly do I also think that the
Queens gambit declined is not a bad
opening in that regard it's something
that can be learned quite quite easily
and it's not very high maintenance
softest yeah he's playing instant moves
my score isn't grade I'm kind of rusty
yeah so it's he's moving around his
queen is he putting it let's see I think
OS has some kind of bloody tactic like
Bishop then 27 I think I overlooked
exactly the same tactic against the same
guy I think I did actually I'm such an
idiot sometimes
G takes Queen d7 everyone looked the
same tactic against this idiotic opening
I'm sorry it isn't it totally erotic
opening where black can be in good shape
with whatever and I'm blundering this
every game I had the same thing I think
it gets exactly the same player now I'm
falling down for nothing basically yeah
okay I have pretty decent development
but it's not
it's not enough
yeah maybe I should just instead of this
play age six or something White's
position is already totally dreadful the
Queen on e4 is completely misplaced it's
complete rubbish there's a question
which player had the biggest impact on
me opening wise Wow I don't know I think
I've looked at all that chrome annex
games when I was younger and I played
many of the this style of openings and
he played before was a good move
so yeah this is just not a good position
yeah I think I'm going to take and hope
that the somewhat reconstruct sure helps
a bit but it's not it's not good in any
way you can put the push up to six the
last cut Rules Committee client is a is
a is a good low maintenance opening it's
just very boring it's very it's a very
high quality opening though so it's
something that can be recommended if you
don't mind a very boring position it
really it really is kind of boring yeah
I also want to say there's a question
what my opinion is of Crum Nick's book
and I'm also not aware of a book that
Chrome Nick wrote yeah maybe he has a
book about his games which was probably
written by not by himself very likely
how many years did it take me to achieve
the IM title quite a long time actually
I only got the title in 2012 so when I
was 38 was very very late I have to say
though that my rating and playing
strength was on that level form for a
long time since the late 90s
but that's um I didn't play much and I
didn't play well when it counted so I
really took a long time to get the
actual title yeah why does do me a good
job him trying to convert the pawn
keeping good control
ganodi sucks to lose against this is
opening it has a funny discussion next
someone says he started to smoke lots of
cigarettes and has increased his rating
yeah this is if that really happened
it's it's a coincidence I can absolutely
assure you that smoking is not a good
idea in any way it's also not good for
your chest I think it was very helpful
for me to stop smoking
not just for chest but but also for
chest
I mean being healthier is useful also
for chest in general but it's also I
mean you lose quite some time you use
quite some time to get outside and and
do the actual smoking yeah it is just
total time waster yeah this is a totally
awful position
where any plays it well I mean as I said
the opening was atrocious but this is
just good play yeah you can do
absolutely nothing it was black I was
small smoking did hurt style I think
it's very likely that he wouldn't have
died oh I just blundered upon amazing
yeah coach no stop smoking a long time
ago yeah can I can resign that bloody
gala yeah it's just like I really hate
to lose against this opening which is
absolutely bad you know like in this
position this is almost lost em if you
play it correctly 97 is strong for black
you can do whatever him and just just
not 94 this is just I had this once
probably against the same player ok so
start let's see if I can do something
against Boris low I really want to get
something going yeah Bri showbiz a
smoker that's true
crowning also I think he took it up
again but yeah but it is it is not these
are the except exceptions that the top
players are all in all pretty need a
pretty healthy lifestyle
I think exercising a lot and taking care
of the health you have the main line
here of the Zurich variation against
Peru slow who castles long Wow
okay
okay I'm taking this why he is a smoker
I doubt that isn't he like 15 or 16 I
mean it doesn't mean that for sure it's
not smoking but it seems unlikely know
the question but then I prefer if I've
ever played a Romanian I am a GM I don't
think so I cannot recall I think I
played I planned I played a W I am last
year I think she was from Romania and
I'm not mistaken miss gillip shut up
gele peep if I'm remembering this
correct but I don't I don't think I've
played a grandmaster
yeah well tower with his smoking and
drinking but okay also had a had a
substantial health problem with those
kidneys so you never know how old he
would have gotten without the drinking
and smoking and so on it sir it's hard
to tell there's a question by without
contrast what I think about 46 against
Quincey to the classical line d6 is a
quite decent line I was thinking to get
this or document that as a secondary
option in my book I ultimately didn't do
it because I felt that the variety of
porn structures was a little bit too
high I wanted something simpler in a
book but the six is perfectly fine so
here he wants to check me
Murilo it's certainly understandable but
it still won't be that easy I hope yes
you want to
he wants to keep to take this porn I
guess yeah
if it takes a five is actually winning a
little bit of time maybe Queen a seven
list is something that would work Queen
a seven in this position check that's at
least a draw
okay let's go Queen eight seven the d6
is fine in the news o against Queen c2
it it is it leads to such a high variety
of porn structures that I I couldn't
really bring myself to recommend it yeah
so I'm I saw that and I thought not to
deform night to d4 should be good
I'm giving up this material
I think it probably wants to return the
material at some point anyway I'm going
to jump in and know how to do this I
would like to I need to put some
pressure on that pawn him somewhere
hopefully 9f8 he might play g5 but it's
tough to keep the night there on h7
aiming for f4 I'm not sure how much that
helps maybe 95 is actually the better
option try to play the night over to a 4
that's if 5 hmm I don't know it doesn't
help much can go to f4 him
let's go to f4 so is there anything that
I can do from here it's difficult to
open this open this position I'm
tightening new c5
um there's a question by Thomas Enders
and how I would approach a 1600 blitz
player with $2,000 tactics as a coach
what format are my lessons any preview
available yeah okay I don't know how how
much I want to advertise my lessons in
during and during a live show yeah I
mean if you if you are good at tactics
but if you like you want to learn more
about strategy I'm definitely help happy
to help there is always some you can
always look at master games to improve
your strategy it's something that I do a
lot in my lessons I look at games of
strong players to see how a middle game
has to be approached
yes he's six that didn't quite okay he
tries to return stuff Wow
what are you doing to me mr. Breslow and
it all works like a charm yeah rook c8
Quincy for even cover c1 remarkable so
it said winning did he find a winning
genius tactic here with c6 seems it does
or seems he did fantastic
I can check him on g6 but this Bishop c2
rook c8 I can still check him behind
morning remarkable wow that seems like a
terrible session here today I don't play
well and my opponents fight all the good
stuff great I think I had a pretty
decent position actually after that he's
changed SEC but if he is finding all the
good stuff not much I can do if you win
games by luck it's not bad being lucky
is a pretty good thing in chess I could
resign everything I hate to resign now I
think after
g6 very strong as hard c6 was was just
very strong yeah two two things are
hanging I have no way to save myself
there c6 excellent I thought that this
would be quite interesting with the good
notes but not so much so my reading has
fallen below 2300 which is kind of
atrocious hmm so I have like 25 minutes
in this stream I need to get back to I
mean me to be low 2,400 makes me feel
bad but below 2300 fields very wrong so
let's get some wins in yeah I will not
pay much attention to the chat and we
win games bill no 2,300 is really bad
come on give me games seems to be
somewhat on the slow side oh we have a
couple of strong players on gain started
are the Reaper man
you know what's always got very strong
opponents here to have to say not like
some easy look at MCM I'm not sure that
he's got the name and no naman no I'm
not going to play lbs counter gaming and
more entertaining openings means like
you want to make on what to see me lose
more and I don't have any beer no I
don't have any beards at all okay so
here we have a new Mizzou style opening
yeah so he give gives me the bishop pair
black in Lodi 594 if he likes or strife
or some other setup what will he do yeah
I think it makes make sense that you get
the Zen so what should you here once to
take on g3 maybe let's block this make a
5 more difficult to play
maybe is playing f5 anyway yeah he does
yeah he's got f4 as a potential move
Frankie Knight says I've failed to sleep
watching my games compared with other
chess youtubers okay well it's a bigger
problem if you fall asleep during chess
if f4 is a problem mm-hmm
Bishop g6 have our Bishop is trapped
this is really an issue
you can also take on f3 here
now I think I have to it looks pretty
awful but they have to
yeah the style the style of chef I mean
I actually don't think I'm not playing
boring Chester's is just come come
completely wrong I mean if you want to
see boring chess I can point you to some
but what I'm trying to do is try to play
correctly and I think it's usually I
mean it's it's rarely incorrect
fireworks you can get lots of that if
you another chance but I simply cannot
play like that I want to play correctly
I mean I'm a chess teacher I cannot play
complete complete rubbish and I also
don't want to yeah this is this is
actually quite quite okay I think for me
ship will come to six it just said my
Bishop 1 h2 is just totally wrong
I need to get some aged foreign yeah the
bishop isn't great I know
have kuna 5 coming so queen f5s got 95
mm okay take this first
hmm
and then I do a country v this is really
a problem
yeah we should f4 is a chick
unfortunately a bishop gee Vanya this
this looks amazing
okay Bishop g3 doesn't help
yeah that bishop oh that bishop is not
good
quite clearly
yeah maybe I am just outplayed that's
very likely with my bishop is so bad but
I don't I don't still think it's totally
easy time warning
yeah the f5 was strong which was very
difficult to avoid h3 check check
oh I didn't see that check oh okay now
then now I'm cheek made it game
why so again I lost him
I've got tough games I mean I'm not
playing well but it's it's tough tough
stuff
it was interesting yeah this may be
efore f5 is just wrong it's very
difficult here to to do something h3 I
know I knew that this is strategically
very difficult but I didn't quite didn't
quite see an alternative the engine does
that place Bishop c2 because of this
this is something I didn't see this is
something I didn't see yeah I have to do
this after h3 I get this get this
position which is really difficult
I'm not completely sure how bad this is
to be honest I know that this is a dead
piece but his King position is very weak
on where weekends it's still kind of
shaky and maybe there are ways to
exploit that but I didn't find it game
started in general you have to be
skeptical about such a position
okay so go head no three it didn't that
way I didn't when he came yet right in
this session okay so I think I should do
this now maybe okay so we've got a goon
felt he would be six
yeah I think I'm taking keeping it
keeping it simple
yep maybe here Bishop c7 is an idea ship
d7 that's a good move and maybe I should
have appreciated a little bit more yeah
okay this is at least very position
that's very much to my taste so I
already hope to do something good with
this I'm a lot better here and I've got
good control okay Bishop c7 is an idea
rook seasickness also quite strong using
this week square
yeah so good control
yeah there's a common Tobiah Bob said
dozy that he liked my coverage my
coverage of famous games yeah I want to
do more that it is currently I don't
have any time the next couple of days
and then I'm on vacation I really think
that mid-august is a good time to start
I kind of want to restart my channel a
little bit do more instructional content
it's not not so easy for me to organize
all those things so pushed him back
there
and they're difficult for black to to
move I think I'm winning some material
here looks like a four
I would definitely look at sad resigned
oh yeah
so I'm not without a win in the session
it's soothing okay
yeah I definitely will do him we'll do
some coverage of kayaking cows and
before the World Championship match but
this is still some some time until it
there's no F FAQ for stuff like my three
favorite chess books that's difficult to
say also there are really lots of great
game starting great books around ok
playing sucker man here I've got 100%
scoring and suckle Mon so let's hope I
can keep that okay so I cannot play
Bishop c5 as I wanted this d4 is an
interesting line I have played this a
bit yeah there's a request for chess
openings uncovered yeah I understand
this is a also something that I like to
do discuss some opening ideas but they
always take quite quite a bit of effort
to to produce it's it's pretty work
heavy content okay so I'm just going to
keep my material here
yeah III was not the most aggressive
move maybe I should have taken on c3 and
make his pawn structure bad but okay
yeah I will I'll start with quick moves
try to be quick in this game yeah maybe
I should produce an FAQ it it's
something maybe for a website that's not
yet not yet live I have quite some
things that I should be getting on the
road but I couldn't always some other
things to do
yeah I'm a pawn up here which is good
but it's not easy here to play I would
like to play Queen to d6 try to get a
tempo on his Bishop and get my knight
unpinned okay
yeah I can play g5 now and Bishop g5 to
to trade yeah I think I really wanted to
trade him the night only five is quite
strong what is he thinking of his this
is always irritating me like what kind
of mood can there be that is not Bishop
sixty-five Bishop c7 this is the answer
okay so Queen c7 okay hmm yeah okay so
we'll have to try to Queen Sam what to
do now I can play Ruby frutti eight
Bishop f3 at this ending but this is
this is not great so I'm going to go for
this ending which is equal
yeah that's a question why I've never
played the Scandinavian yeah I think I
said it before and some other show I
don't like the Scandinavian pawn
structure that much not that it is
particularly bad it's just not something
that I enjoy playing yeah this is an
equal ish position I think we'll see
what happens
to activate the king maybe I can get in
G for get the you Foursquare for my
bishop I try to be active here I mean
not really a check sure that it helps
much maybe I should have just done
nothing but it's not really in my nature
to do nothing oh I always try to do
something this is also by the way why I
don't understand why people someone
would say I'm playing particularly
boring as I just don't unless you really
think chess is some kind of game but you
should play some crap and hope for the
best
I mean you can play in correct openings
gambits whatever but it's just not
particularly good yeah so what I did
here I was just too ambitious again why
this better now should have done
something normal and just keep the
position as is I cannot play route b6
because of bloody Bishop c7 shoot yeah
he played this well and what I did is
just it wasn't good it just wasn't good
okay I tried to do something with my C
pawn him
yeah the other said I don't think the
Scandinavian is bad it's just that I
don't I don't enjoy playing this the
pawn structures that arise not my cup of
tea so or whoopsie for him yeah I can
also do this yeah maybe I'm still okay
here I don't quite understand what the
b-pawn is doing here I mean I'm just
taking on this next okay so I didn't
screw it up which is good news
so here I can check you there check here
take on g3 which is kind of risky okay
it's also kind of interesting check
check check
this is chick made right shouldn't do
this check so I'm probably going to win
this on time actually no chance to win
on position
check time warning white forfeits what a
second game and at least over the 2300
so ok let's see about some questions
nothing in particular I'm going to play
another game maybe I can make a small
small serious on this like three three
three nil in the last couple of games
okay grandmaster arc and it's Korra
right akshar Cora okay so we get them
reversed Benoni and interesting it's not
playing and you five
okay I'm happy to trade this I'm not a
huge fan
generally speaking of the reverse Benoni
but this is kind of okay I already have
traded some things which is which is
nice traded some pawns
I wonder if III is an interesting with
him as he has a hard time to play e5
yeah he has to take basically and then I
get a very nice center
there's also Knight h4 as a possible for
Knight f5 but Knight c5 might be good so
I'm going to go deform and maybe you can
take twice oh that would have been very
risky I think I'll play a lazy move here
there's a question do I mind saying
about your family life I'm not sure what
that means
so I've gained some space yeah I don't
know if I want to go before him yeah
let's let's go for for the space he's
going to try to go to the six here with
this yep maybe Bishop d7 b5 coming up
okay let's jump in yeah I'm not totally
happy with this position I have to see
my bishop is quite bad you can't go III
what am I doing here
Wow I'm just not playing any attention
here or this one
we Wow
okay it's very long David this is pretty
awful okay wait
that was very embarrassing let's go for
another game I cannot stop with this
with this terrible game boom I'm okay
that was awful
now I didn't like this position somehow
maybe I shouldn't have played 83 and
this is I probably have just probably
have to avoid d5 in this my night is bad
on detune yeah this d5 doesn't it's just
not great I have to keep the tension in
this position somehow game started okay
ma Tulio is the game and this will be
the final
of the session I'm below 2,300 again and
Matt's idea was also somewhat I have
four years for four out of five but
currently he's probably has a good
chances yet you to get something yeah
okay so let's get some space going so
needless to say that this this is not
particularly great here likes opening I
guess but okay that you're just that
looks really bad
I mean how is he justifying all this 95
maybe or something
Wow
okay so okay let's start with this yeah
I'm not sure I want to talk about my
family in the Honda on the day on this I
don't think it's very appropriate so how
should you the same I think probably
taking into F for Bishop age five check
is something that I probably should be
going for the thing is he's got the
chick on d3 this is something that I
only now saw and we should check king of
AIDS
Kareena for Queen f6 this is not so
great I take with the bishop from finish
form
I'd like to prevent as castling of
course if possible but I don't quite see
if this is really really on and maybe
still this if you play screen f6 now I
can't play castles long Bishop g5
against long castles now a still plays
again what's the deal maybe just
sacrifices on f2
now that should that should really work
completely still somewhat somewhat
tricky position so here what's what's
happening look f-14 look f8 maybe look
f1 q h4 probably I also have Queen h6 as
a possible move Queen age six ways it
going with the bishop I mean I don't see
where I actually don't I don't see him
probably I'm overlooking something that
but I don't think you would see a movie
maybe 93 check and then Bishop takes c3
or some stuff something like this 93 I
can also play rook t3 should work
actually at this one
I didn't even see that yeah okay I said
it's been a long day and I should see
this move it's not difficult
check
rook age one he has his check and yes
between age six check as well it's not
threatened that much I don't think I've
been to 2000 and I really don't I really
don't think that happened I mean I I
cannot remember maybe to 190 or
something with below is really tough
Bishop age five here this was a move but
93 check
no I can check here time warning the
king will go to d6 of all places
check it was below 2,100 yeah maybe I
can honestly don't matter
maybe Queen g8 was possible here it I
wanted some security I'm down to some
seconds 36
yeah he's six I don't see how he's
covering it maybe 95 start working hard
to believe 28 check before is hanging is
the problem this is really an issue so I
cam taking this first 25 this is 6
there are firms falling asleep here and
this is not a good idea and what's the
probably losing what a bad session
what a bad session check check
Oh Jack Jack now you a long time
somewhere with pre moving [ __ ]
Jack I could press the draw button with
nine hundredths of a second
whoo yeah okay I was a pretty awful
session yeah I really hope I'm in better
shape next time next week you may be it
will be better but yeah I'm kind of
rusty I don't play blitz chance at the
moment it all just in this session here
okay I saw I still hope you enjoyed the
session quite a bit you want to see me
suffer you had some good chances this
time okay I'll be back next week next
Monday with a with hopefully a better
run yeah thanks guys bye bye